patty Saylor you like spider-man I could
show you a pretty good time hop in try
not to show the background too much they
could triangulate our location a
triangle in the location yeah I don't
want to get Gavin freed which is a sad
[ __ ] thing to say I'm so sorry that
that happened yeah that's that's like
sighs [ __ ] so anyway its 7:35 whatever
day September seventh or sixth whichever
it's Thursday night we are going to pick
up the game as the title of set video
implies said video said video um what I
want to talk about while we were on the
way there is I think it would be
interesting to just bring up how
complicated my relationship with this
game has become like like any spider-man
fan I'm like super [ __ ] excited
obviously right I mean look at this
thing looks amazing but there's just so
much other stuff that's happened and has
gone on since that is kind of like kind
of shifted my perception a little bit
and made it harder to be excited put
your seatbelt on yeah
God Thomas you're such a put your seat
belt on you unsafe bastard you're gonna
die listen I'll tell you whenever I want
even on like one of the biggest
spider-man fans on the [ __ ] planet
like you know I've read all the comics
you can you can show me a cover of a
spider-man comic from like any of the
main ongoings and I can tell you what
happens in it just from the cover and
someone that is that obsessed with this
character you think would be like beside
himself excited
the laylee have just had so much anxiety
about this game like every time people
talk about how close we are to it coming
out it doesn't feel like a man I can't
believe we have to wait that long it's
it feels like this like ticking clock
feels like like a Doomsday Clock like 72
hours like oh no and I wonder why that
is like what exactly is causing that
I mean sure there's like you know this
Spidey squad drama that's always
happening I want to get too into that
it's like well people say things on
Twitter or social media about the game
that's you know even if it's not like
just full-on praise they have a tendency
to get attacked and or just like at the
point where they're afraid to even talk
about it anymore like a lot of people
told me that they're feeling like
fatigue about it because of that it's
this special topic that you're not
allowed to criticize or or have any like
question is about that might reflect
poorly on the game
so for the people who've made it yeah I
get it though it's like III honestly I
was really hype when I saw the first
trailer for it y'all were everyone was
like you had that one scene where he was
jumping through the building I'm sure
that's gonna be something like quick
time maybe
yeah just looks like there's a lot of
QuickTime events which I'm fine with I
guess I think one of the things that is
holding it back for me is that because
of like how big the spider-man
retrospective got which is pretty damn
big like I died tallied it up the views
of that entire series add up to a little
over three million it's a lot of people
who adore that series from me and are
waiting with bated breath for me to do
the next one and there's a lot of high
expectations for this new video like
some people who are telling me that
they're more excited for my video on the
game than the game itself and that is a
weird thing to hear that that kind of
freaks me out and makes me stressed is I
think like god that's a lot of pressure
because I hope the video is good then on
top of that it's like I got to make this
kick-ass review but also I got to be
careful what I say because we've set
this precedent where if you are super
positive you're gonna get in trouble
uncharted 4 nonsense remember that the
guy gave it a like a pre like lukewarm
score it was like ads all right and then
like people like demanded that his
publication like fire him and make him
do a new review where he said it was
perfect he just said he didn't like it
that much is just oh yeah there
shouldn't be a point of controversy ya
wallet or like Ryan Reynolds and Green
Lantern
well how do you figure well look as like
you know you you go into something like
hey hell yeah we can do this and we can
do this really well and then like it
turn you get to like the end and Pete
it's not selling and even like the
directors are basically like we just
sell in this movie as our own but
they're forever engraved into the movie
as you know directed by blah blah yeah
like they're their names always gonna be
attached to it so I'm always gonna be
attached to spider-man games and there's
always gonna be that question of life
what you think a new one where you can
do a video on here you can do livestream
are you gonna do let's play like the
high expectations and again I'm really
scared like I'm I've sometimes I have
like like panic attacks thinking like
what if I say that like I didn't like a
boss fight from it and it was really
boring right and then people freaked out
and talks me right like just because
that that sounds like an insane
overreaction and like it wouldn't happen
but that does happen people freaked out
like that you know do I censor my
opinion and do a video that's just
overly positive just so I can both get
them off my back and also not piss them
off or should I be honest because if
there's stuff I'm not gonna like I feel
like I ought I ought to myself and the
audience to say so plus I think the
video would be more entertaining if I
wasn't just praising it infinitely bowl
away through I feel like my most boring
videos are the ones where I'm just like
this games awesome the whole way through
like my ultimate spider-man review
Bataan Death March yeah I'm being walked
to my suicide point dude relax Logan
pull oh my god you could put Logan Paul
on your title
clickbait here's I'll just put it up on
screen all right that'll be what what
the the clickbait thumbnail will be
don't know what people want anymore
dude you sound like you having an
existential crisis right now I kind of
am that's what the Thoth at the sandwich
metaphors are about it's a delicate line
of giving people what they want but also
staying true to yourself as a creator
yeah artsy
wait for an hour and then they put it
out will they put it up dressing it's
what happened
so apparently at this fine establishment
which is known for swell business
practices
apparently it's not gonna be available
until midnight even though everyone
keeps saying nine o'clock release online
I all right I'm fine I guess we'll go
somewhere else you want to try one of
the game stops the mall this is gonna be
a [ __ ] show that's kind of what I was
hoping for I want it to be an adventure
it'd be boring if we just got it on the
first try you [ __ ] kidding me
you're gonna walk I all love it's not
that far but I really don't feel like
walking today all right how about a
really nice lazy day I just want the way
that way yeah all right that exact I
also don't even know if they're still
open right now so find out I'll be well
they have their hours other up till
10:00 okay walking in there probably
turn the camera off for now so what was
that they didn't have it either
apparently they don't get new games they
get it like a couple weeks after the
fact I just want to check since it was
on the way game stops still the main
goal I know everyone's probably in the
comments going why didn't you just
[ __ ] preorder it so you just go pick
it up stupid because I actually kind of
like this no I mean I know it might be
annoying for some people but I don't
know I just have the fun just going on
the hunt I guess I guess you do it's
special bowlers conflict because we want
the game but we're not getting it which
means that there's something to do life
is boring if everything is just easy
that's right
so struggle honestly it's actually more
interesting me I actually kind of like
that we're doing this because it means I
get to hang out with my friend a little
longer and we get to walk around in
pocket and alright so we got the thingy
I bought it an hour in advance so we're
gonna wait
about nine o'clock since we're a little
early and then we'll be one of the first
people to get it so coming here it
really was a good idea now we won't have
to wait in line there nearly as long
we're like number 10 out of like god
knows how many
they the employees are really cool and
actually asked me why we had a camera
and
about about the channel and everything
and I actually recommended in my videos
to a couple people and showed them
this yeah
so we're just gonna bomb around and wait
until nine o'clock and then pick it up
again we're trying to remember where
exactly in this place you can buy dildos
because I know that's a thing I couldn't
remember which store was but I know
there's one of them I'm gonna have to
remember for I'm not gonna finish that
joke I think you take it all right there
it is I'm holding the camera now skip
merrily on your way there my boy I know
if I just trip and die
you like ruined all the fun of an
escalator
you'd like miss the point entirely of
why the escalator is fun
you're a disappointment you're a
disappointment that's
I'm not going to fight y'all now
hey it's not like it's not fun
I'm sorry call sorry go let's eat turkey
sandwiches together
I don't like Turkey you [ __ ]
hey the times about here we're about to
get in line don't take it out from the
game stop it small
you know I think developers of this game
might hate me that's reasonable but no
like I actually think because James
Stevenson unfollowed me on Twitter even
blocked me it's not followed me straight
up on phone cuz I did someone leaked a
list of what the costumes were and I
post it was like hey here's what I think
these costumes are cuz it was just like
tiny little thumbnail logos of like the
chances on them yeah I was like here's
what I think I'm seeing here and I did
like a whole threat on Twitter I was
like I think this suit is this one which
is from this book and like just like the
thing like that and the community
director the game developer got so
pissed off that the unfollowed me and I
was look just because you're reversed
spider-man fan doesn't mean yes the girl
but her that you know what symbols are
what oh it's not it's just because I I
mean it is kind of a spoiler and I
posted that and that's on me but it's I
mean it's gnarliest
story spoilers so much it's a spoiler
for here's what suits are gonna be in
the game and even then I actually some
might here's what I was speculating it's
some of what I put on the list was wrong
I wasn't trying to spoil anything for
anyone just because I also had assumed
that everyone is gonna see that [ __ ]
list by the end of the day eventually if
not you someone else yeah right so I
don't know and that might be a flimsy
just
but I didn't think it would be too
harmful but I feel like James Stevenson
might hate me I also deemed insomniac
games on their Twitter once just trying
to show them my series and like you know
tell them about myself so maybe I could
get kind of been good with them they
didn't reply and then eventually close
their DMS not because of me I think
because everyone started harassing him
about the Randi suit but uh thus far my
attempts at CI know they're aware of me
because the community director followed
me on Twitter like this is kind of a big
thing but I don't think they like me I
think I'm too provocative for them I'm
not quite like in an agreeable kind of
golden boy that you can just use that
for type of game like like I'm I'm
controversial and I'm okay with that
good respect them to want want me around
because I'm kind of a crazy [ __ ]
sometimes
[Applause]
got it
dude what a fun adventure that what up
what a fun adventure think of all the
times dude we'll look at old look at
this one we're famous and be like oh my
god that's what got us started yeah
this is where rhythm real money weird
the mall we're coming out now we just
got it ya know what we did but they said
they wouldn't have it till midnight so
we went to the mall and just like
pre-order didn't our before Spider Man
rise of Doc Ock probably since he's most
likely the bad guy you know I I think
doctor Doc Ock is the main bad guy
unless he's been the biggest thing since
2017 because Dan Slott this apparently
has his hooks in the story and you know
he can't help himself he makes Doc Ock
the main bad guy and everything just
mean yes huh
don slots behind it all Dan Slott yeah
Dan Slott dressed his Doc Ock Dan Slott
okay
he can't keep his dick out of Doc Ock
this box aren't also very bland you
could do something way cooler I wanted
them to use the Alex Ross cover that
would have been way cooler in fact I
hope this thing's reversible so that's
in there alright see you in a few
minutes then but oh boy is that a pretty
long install time this is why
PlayStation is better everyone you put
your game in and then you get to be
excited to play it for a whole extra two
hours before it's ready you don't get
that experience with Xbox delicious if
there is actually story DLC like
expansions where you fight extra
villains like there's a there's a DLC
with blackhat where you she pulled heist
put a scorpion in this yes okay why do
you like scorpion now I just is have a
distinct memory of really hating a
mission at one of the older things
listen you could go into twitch right
now and the biggest thing in gaming is
gonna be spider-man ps4 see the other
than for denied arm other than fortnight
[Music]
[Music]